camille de noray psychologue depuis une
quinzaine d'années elles rencontrent
chaque jour des patients avec des
problématiques très variés juste après
le confinement
elle a vu une hausse de sa clientèle un
jeune qui peut lui malheureusement
devait signer un contrat de travail
prendre ses vacances au début du
confinement démarrer un travail il a
rien eu il s'est retrouvé chez ses
parents pendant tout le confinement ses
parents ont tendance à toucher un peu à
l'alcool
très régulièrement on va dire lui il
s'est mis à boire de plus en plus et
puis vraiment le dernier mois du
confinement il exprime un sentiment de
dépression un profond vraiment un vide
un vide abyssal
aujourd'hui il retravaille il va un peu
mieux mais tout ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce confinement
il a ça a mis en lumière des
problématiques familiales qu'il avait
avant
mais de façon tellement forte qu'il a
une angoisse permanente qui ressent
toujours la période de covin n'est pas
fini ce qui angoisse les plus fragiles
d'ailleurs les troubles liés au
confinement peuvent apparaître plusieurs
mois après en fait on voit que les
débuts on va voir beaucoup de monde on
va avoir beaucoup d'effet on va de plus
en plus et notamment à cause aussi des
masques
les enfants souffrent des masques donc
les écrans plus les masques les enfants
niveau du lien il va y avoir des
problèmes qui ont qui vont arriver mais
ça on va voir les effets dans 6 9 mois
et les effets du confinement se sont
ressentis aussi sur les couples pour
cette médiatrice familiale
il s'agit de leur donner un espace pour
communiquer dans de bonnes conditions
la plupart des couples reconnaissent que
la fragilisation du lien familial n'est
pas exclusivement due au confinement
dans la grande partie des cas ils me
disent c'est pas ça qui a causé
voilà la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes dans le conflit dans lequel nous
sommes
mais ça a été un révélateur voilà
révélateur très fort de deux choses qui
a dépeint comme si on s'était retrouvé
le face à face face à nos difficultés
face à nos problèmes et le télétravail
qui tend à se généraliser ne va pas
faire avancer les choses
certains auront besoin de plusieurs
séances pour atténuer leurs névroses
d'autres au bout seulement de trois
séances auront réglé leur problème